وفي بريطانيا قضت المحكمه العليا
البريطانيه اليوم بقانونيه خطه الحكومه
لترحيل طالبي لجوء الى رواندا وكانت
الحكومه وقعت اتفاقا في ابريل لسان الماضي
لارسال الاف طالب اللجوء غير النظاميين
الى رواندا الى حين البث في طلباتهم لكن
الرحله الاولى في يونيو الماضي اوقفت في
اللحظات الاخيره بسبب تدخلات قانونيه في
بريطانيا وفي محكمه حقوق الانسان
الاوروبيه لكن المحكمه قالت ايضا في حكمها
بانه على الحكومه ان تعيد النظر في حالات
ثمانيه من طالب اللجوء كانت تعتزم ترحيلهم
الى رواندا
انا من لندن مراسل الجزيره اسد الله
الصاوي هذه القضيه تثير الكثير من الجدل
هل يمكن القول ان الجاد الحسن الان بعد
هذا القرار من المحكمه العليا
زين اولا الامر يعتبر مصر سياسي للحكومه
البريطانيه من حيث ان هناك الكثير من
جمعيات حقوق الانسان وجمعيه الدفاع عن
اللاجئين التي كانت تشد في قانونيه هذه
الخطوه الان على المحكمه قالت ان هذه
الخطوه وهذه السياسه قانونيه ولا تتعارض
مع ميثاق الامم المتحده لحقوق الانسان
وبالتالي يمكن للحكومه المضيف لها ولكن في
ذات الوقت المحكمه قالت ان هناك ثمانيه
اشخاص كان يفترض ان يرحلوا في شهر يونيو
والماضي لم تقم الحكومه بما عليها بما
يكفي لدراسه ملفاتهم قبل ارسالهم الى همم
بطابعه من المعروف ان عمليه الارسال هي
روندا الى رواندا هي حتى يتم البث في
طلبات اللجوء المقدمه منها هؤلاء طالب
اللجوء هؤلاء غير الموضوعين الذين يصلون
الى شواطئ بريطانيا في قوارب او عبر همم
يعني شاحنات من همم فرنسا وما الى ذلك
ايضا همم تحدي يوم قانوني همم اخر لهذه
السياسه في المحكمه الاوروبيه لحقوق
الانسان على الحكومه ان تجدد هذه ان تجتاز
هذه العقبه اولا ومحكمه المحكمه العليا
البريطانيه اليوم عندما حكمت بان هذه
السياسه القانونيه قالت انها ساخر حكمها
الى الشهر القادم ما اذا كان يمكن الطاعن
على حكم المحكمه هذا اليوم ام لا وبالتالي
حتى هذا الحكم يمكن ربما اطانا عليه في
شهر يناير المقبل وعلى هذا الاساس لا يمكن
القول ان الحكومه يمكن ان يعني الان في
ترحيل اللاجئين الى روان
قصد الله الصاوي
[موسيقى]